our bodies contain all sorts of
microscopic organisms like bacteria and
viruses some of these are pathogens that
can cause disease animals bodies have
them too
when a pathogen jumps from one species
to another species that isn't familiar
with it it can exploit that new hosts
lack of defenses and cause illness the
pathogen that moves from animals to
humans is called a zoonosis diseases
like West Nile virus and Ebola both
originated this way and researchers
think covered 19 did too
among humans the majority of new disease
outbreaks are the result of zoonotic
diseases and for the last few decades
the number of zoonotic disease outbreaks
has been increasing looking at this
chart it might seem like humans are the
victims of an onslaught of pathogens
from animals but what if these outbreaks
are increasing because of something
humans are doing
there's a lot of things we're doing that
are increasing the probability of
pandemic caused and pathogens emerging
this is Sonia Shah she's a science
journalist who writes about the history
of pandemics right now we've used up
over half of the terrestrial surface of
the planet humans have been using more
and more land for hundreds of years but
that land use has accelerated in the
last hundred years
today satellite imagery shows us exactly
what this expansion looks like we are
expanding our cities erasing forests and
reshaping the land for agriculture and
sometimes that expansion is the result
of war that's what happened here in West
Africa it's an area that today includes
Sierra Leone Guinea and Liberia there's
a forest that once covered that area
where the three countries meet
throughout the 1990s civil wars in this
region killed thousands and forced many
more from their homes hundreds of
thousands of refugees fled into that
forest they cut down a lot of those
trees they're making way for their homes
and cutting down trees for charcoal and
farming etc and you can actually see the
change in the forest cover in satellite
images if you look at the early 70s
satellite images it's almost all green
and then you look at late 1990s and it's
mostly brown because only a small
fraction of the original forests
remained here in a village in Guinea is
where researchers think an outbreak of
Ebola began at the end of 2013 like the
rest of the region this village used to
be a forest and also happens to be a
natural habitat for wild bats
researchers believe the outbreak started
with a boy named Emile who died after he
was exposed to fluids from a bat
carrying Ebola which quickly spread from
his family to his village to other
villages
as humans develop and transform wild
animal habitats events like the Ebola
outbreak are becoming more and more
likely we're paving over wildlife
habitat which means it's much more
likely that pathogens that live inside
animal bodies will make their way into
human bodies and that's because animals
end up living much closer to us but in
many cases those animals don't survive
human encroachment into their habitats
in the first place this chart shows the
biggest extinction threats facing
different animal groups for most of them
the biggest threat to survival isn't
pollution or being hunted it's the loss
of their habitat and a disappearing
species creates a different opportunity
for zoonotic diseases to jump to humans
take West Nile virus for example it
originates in birds that migrate from
Africa to North America in the summer it
typically infects humans through
mosquitoes but West Nile virus was never
a problem in the u.s. until 1999 that's
because we had a diversity of bird
species in our domestic bird flu in a
diverse bird population some species are
good carriers of West Nile virus and
some aren't North America once had a
large population of birds like
woodpeckers and rails that don't easily
carry the virus that made it much harder
for the virus to spread among the bird
population but then we started
disrupting those birds habitats what's
happened over the past 50 years is we've
lost a lot of that avian biodiversity
woodpeckers and rails are now pretty
rare what we now have instead are a lot
of pieces like American robins and crows
crows and Robins are much more adaptable
to a changed environment but they also
happen to be better carriers of West
Nile virus
the fewer web peckers and rails you have
around and the more our robins and crows
you have around the more West Nile virus
you have around in your domestic bird
flocks and the more likely it becomes
that a mosquito will bite an infected
bird and then by a human and that
exactly what happened in New York City
in 1999 before 1999 no one in the US had
ever died from West Nile virus since
then around a hundred and fifty people
in the US have died from it every year
the places where humans are encroaching
on wildlife are the frontier for the
next pandemic that means one thing
scientists can do to prevent it is to
watch those places really closely we
don't know which microbe is gonna cause
the next outbreak or pandemic but we do
know how that happens and so we can
really do active surveillance in those
places where it's most likely to occur
places where there's a lot of invasion
of wildlife habitat but preventing
future outbreaks might also require us
to rethink our relationship with nature
and to understand that as we take over
more and more of the planet there's a
cost to the animals that live there but
also to us
[Music]
you
[Music]